Wow look at you
I guess you took the hard road happy -
you think we'd learn now on the name of
progress right
they say there's always something better
burn the old bring in the new know how'd
that work out
risk their whole future and we trusted
them and that we fight them any way we
can
for what's left of humanity
[Music]
I'm sorry where you do having a moment I
can leave you all be 1 the graph cycle
I'm a pilot it's called a pre-flight
inspection
[Applause]
what you guys think of that looks pretty
cool right we got Marcus from v1 here
Marcus this is so cool that this
integration is real you showed the real
gameplay there you and I first started
talking about this game I think like
five years ago and you're just a couple
people right we're talking about the
first game Awards of 2014 you're like
maybe we'll kick start this and here we
are five years later you've got a bigger
team now right we do we have a we
started out with three yes and now we
have a small team of 30 people at v1 in
the Seattle area back out in the Pacific
Northwest yes well you're known for
doing some cool things out there Pacific
Northwest with certainly you know
co-creator halo Master Chief and this is
something brand new tell us about this
new character figure alright we've got a
new character we're playing his name is
Romer he's trained grab cycle pilot it's
one of these vehicles that you saw
flying in the game yeah it's a game
pretty much unlike anything you've ever
played before and you're doing campaign
and multiplayer for that is true we have
a story a full single-player story
campaign as well as a huge multiplayer
component to it as well
okay well let's talk about some of the
gameplay we saw there because people you
know know sort of you know first-person
action games and tell us about the style
of gameplay and how you're playing there
and explain what people are saying sure
it's saying it's a first-person shooter
with a lot of real-time tactic elements
blended in so you play as a pilot in
this grab cycle vehicle that hovers
above the ground and you have onboard
weapons for offensive and defensive
capability as well as then commanding a
small squad of units on the ground that
each have their own unique ability so
it's your job to use them strategically
in gameplay it's really cool yeah it
looks amazing and it's got that you know
the feel that I think we know we know
and love from you know halo destiny is
sort of an epic world the great music I
mean it's a lot of signatures there but
it's new and different game it's all in
my DNA well the fact that you're doing
you know campaign and multiplayer I
think is absolutely amazing with a team
of 30 or something that looks that
flings yeah we are taking on something
pretty ambitious with a title
this but the 30 person team in Seattle
is a powerhouse of talent of a triple-a
devs like myself as well as I'm a lot of
emerging talent so it's it's a great mix
this is definitely a game to watch 2020
but now you're gonna let people play it
I mean it's here at Gamescom that's
right
we're playing multiplayer on the floor
so we're pretty excited to have a pretty
buddy jump into a 5v5
pretty frenetic great experience on
multiplayer so it's pretty great I love
you guys announcing the game letting
people play it right here at Gamescom it
looks phenomenal good luck with it
hoping to see more of it soon thank you
integration Marcus and be one awesome
free camp thanks Marcus
all right now we're gonna take a look at
a trailer for Darksiders Genesis coming
out later this year
[Applause]